hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and today we're talking
about porn I am person who loves VR and
I also recognize that the porn industry
kind of solidifies forms of media VHS
became successful women you get porn
with sellable on it the same thing
applies to DVD and also kind of the
internet if porn can exist on something
and make money on something that thing
is probably going to be successful
considering how much ponents consumed so
with my love of the off I want to be our
pond to be successful in order for VR to
be successful but right now it's
terrible and terrifying I did check out
some VR porn earlier this year I tried
something from a company called Naughty
America and I was using a gear VR for my
horrific experience now there are two
reasons that VR porn doesn't walk yet
I'm sure it will but right now it
absolutely does not the first one is a
scale so to backtrack and just paint a
picture of what VI point actually is you
sit in chair or I guess playing a bed or
you know whatever you want to do man
it's up to you and you put the thing on
your face and then you're presented with
a room that basically covers all of your
peripheral vision directly in front of
me was a female's body just laying down
and it basically functions like point of
view point so it's you are watching
someone else do something to what is
supposed to be you so the problem is
then when other people are introduced in
both the male and female versions you
will be like laying down and then
somebody climbs on top of you and
because of the way that scale works they
are a giant it doesn't look like a
normal person who's just kind of sitting
on top of you it looks like a [ __ ]
Amazon human that is just totally out of
proportion it's just that so it's kinda
like you know your pin pointed at the
genitals and then their upper body just
kind of
use up words and out of control to the
point of their face looks like a
two-story building as someone who has
not ever directed porn or you know
anything else I don't know why that's
happening I don't know what it is about
the camera setup that made the person
who is virtually on top of me will look
like a [ __ ] mountain but it was scary
so that brings us to point two of the
problem with VR porn so I was always
putting the VR headset on the guy who
was giving it to me it said something
along the lines of just so you know this
is pretty intense
and then I put it on and I had to take
it off because I was so uncomfortable
and when I did take it off the guy said
that every woman who's tried it pretty
much reacts the same way which is
laughing and then taking the headset off
basically meaning extreme discomfort the
reason for this and I think this is
different for guys than it is to women
is a power thing so what was virtually
presented to me was that I was laying on
a bed I think a dude that I'm not at all
attracted to walks into the room it was
like some beefy ball yeah with awful
tattoos and then he just starts
virtually doing stuff to my virtual body
wands Lang melon I had no way of
interacting it was like I was just
laying there and watching so it was like
a weird anti-choice simulation in that
and it was really gross I feel like this
probably isn't the same for guys who
watch it because the guys that I went
with didn't feel the same way about that
they did feel the same way about the
weird [ __ ] Amazon people and how
terrifying that was but the power thing
I think with the context of being a
woman just makes you very uncomfortable
so the two problems are one the scale is
ridiculous and just doesn't look right
at all and then two you have no input so
it really didn't work for me suddenly a
factor and something that would
contribute to success but I also
understand why the company who is making
this isn't focusing on women immediately
when men watch majority of porn and also
I guess for any women who are into that
kind of thing I just feel like
probably most aunt so I guess to fix it
I would say they would have to have some
kind of interactivity or a semblance of
power and also fix the [ __ ] Amazon
person thing cuz that's not great either
but of course the lovers really only
just come out and I've only seen it once
and it was at the start of this year so
maybe it's changed quite a lot since
then and I'm sure people are constantly
innovating to try to get porn to work on
VR because that's the way that new kind
of hardware works alright guys that is
it for me I just thought that it's
something that I've experienced it's not
a lot of other people also I would share
my thoughts on that one and where it's
headed and what it means for Rio thank
you guys so much for watching I will see
you next time